hello everyone and welcome to a really
impressive game that was played to two
days ago in the Aeroflot open tournament
in round five it's Indian Grandmaster a
Beeman you put an inverse this Russian
Grandmaster salmon Suvorov we already we
already checked out a few games by Sugar
Grove on this channel his most notable
one being his win against Magnus Carlsen
this day considered maybe cousin's worst
defeat ever from the 2010 chess olympiad
if you haven't seen that game I will put
a link to it in the description below it
will be the first thing you see so if
you want to check that game out as well
but yeah really impressive stuff and I
saw two days ago and even yesterday that
a lot of people were sharing the
positions from this game on Twitter and
I thought okay those are very nice
positions but then I actually saw the
game and the game was even better so
without further ado let's check it out
put an ik opens with Knight to f3 and
sugar replies with the d5 it's my
favorite reply to the red team we have
g3 and g6 now both players are ready to
fianchetto their bishops Bishop g2
Bishop g7 we have castles and now here
by some well principals you you want to
play d4 here you kind of don't want to
allow black this a5 move but here white
what does it but these are modern times
and modern approach to chess is seen
every day so abandoning the center we
have castles and the now 'if I've and
with this with this to two central pawns
black has incredible central control
we have d3 by white now ready to
challenge the center with the center
with E for we have 97 preparing the
castle and E for now we have castles
captures on d5 Knight captures on d5 and
now rook to e1 adding another attacker
to the pawn developing the rook 96
defending and now Knight to c3 and here
declining the trade going back Knight to
d7 preparing to remain over this Knights
to f5 we have rook to b1 still
considered a standard theory when black
a defense the way black does getting the
rook away from this diagonal also and of
supporting the b-pawn beef before it's
ready to be
Plato a five sugar of prevents this and
now b3 preparing to fianchetto the dark
square Bishop as well Knight f5 and
excellent square for the night white
will not have an easy task getting rid
of it now and now Knights the b5 and
this position has been reached before h6
is a known move in this position but
here we have ripped it by Sugarloaf and
it is as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so d5 pawn nicely
defended and whites the play
we have Bishop to b2 adding more
pressure to the e5 pawn and now black
starts with a 4 he wants to bust open
the position here maybe bring the rook
over to a2 so here white place B
captures an a4 and it's a it's a bit of
a weird move there was also be 4 in the
position before it's very nice then you
can solidify with a3 and of course if
Knight captures you just capture on e5
and you open up and attack tonight so
before was definitely an interesting
idea if you trade captures then you can
capture on b4 and now you can't even go
back at the g7 you have to keep an eye
on the pawn here and it's it's a it's
very uncomfortable for black if you go
here then just well capture scalpers
Knight captures here wins the material
for white so instead after a 4 we have B
captures on a4 and now rook captures on
a4 and a3 now so not waiting for c4
which would open up a discovery to the
rook we have looked back to a 8 and now
a c4 strengthening the night here on b5
but it does leave white without with a
backwards d3 pawn which which might be
an issue but okay we have Knight to d6
now offering a trade here trying to get
rid of White's active knight on d5 and
Queen to b3 now also with Knight to d6
black is preparing a 4 which would maybe
remove the defender of the c4 pawn so
here by playing Queen to b3 the c4 pawn
is also nicely guarded we have Bishop to
f5 that's not a bishop continuing
development depending the pawn as the
rook is still on beat one and now rook
beat d1 defending the pawn also at some
point white might be ready to get rid of
his backwards pawn and Queen to d7 are
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and now a four by why
in okay we have rook a to d8 and now c5
pushing the knight back and now well you
could capture it will only improve
White's pawn structure so here at Bishop
to e6 first and this is the start of a
most incredible attack which you'll see
the Queen is under attack we have Queen
back to a3 and now Knight to c4 and we
read you the position from the thumbnail
where we're all held basically breaks
loose
the queen is under attack also the
bishop the problem is you don't have the
luxury of declining this peace offering
because if you move the Queen let the
Queen b3 just characters capture sandy
for just wins the game as your queen is
now under attack and the night you're
gonna lose a piece and well you can
simply resign so here you have to
capture the night which is what quranic
does d captures on c4 but now comes
Queen captures on d1 and here what
happens if the queen is captured if the
queen is captured then rook captures
with Czech Bishop to F 1 and now Bishop
to h3 just piling up on the bishop here
and it's not game over for y just yet
because Knight d2 kind of saves white
now you can give up a piece back and
then white white white can get more and
more defenders to the back rank
however rook d8 now attacks the knight
this way but still white has to resort
to some trickery like Knight to d6 not
allowing rook captures here and then you
would get something like C captures and
e6 and now after Queen b3 attacking the
rook rook e1 but White is still barely
holding on Bishop to h6 is coming once
you eliminate eliminate the night rook
captures an F 1 is coming so that's what
happens if you capture the Queen's so
Knight captures on c7 and it's it's
really just a crazy position the Queen
is still under attack what do you do
here so here if you move back the Queen
which is possible let's say Queen d7 it
really turns into a funny line Knight
captures any eight rook captures any
eight Bishop captures on e5 Knight
captures on e5 sorry Knight captures on
e5 Knight captures Bishop characters and
not rook captures on e5
now Queen 31 with Chuck Bishop to f1 and
now it's it's it's very funny because
Bishop to h3 is not possible because
rook captures with shirt and after King
g7 you don't have made because Quinta c3
check is is enough for for white to save
the game however after Bishop to f1 you
have this very interesting f6 move which
frees the f7 Square for the King and now
after the rook moves let's say rookie
for now you have Bishop captures on c4
and also a lot of a lot of crazy stuff
can happen
rook captures any eight and now you have
to go King g7 and now well if Black gets
a move it's just over so here the game
would basically end in a repetition
rookie 7 King goes back check check King
goes back here check problem is if King
goes to f8 then then again white is
completely winning but even it's a
position that never happened but still
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea here for white as
it's a it's a really funny thing well
I'll give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on spotting this win in
this position that never actually
happened and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's actually
rook to eat ooh yes you block you can
you block mate and then well you have to
play something Bishop captures any two
and then now comes c6 with check and now
the problem is you don't have a good
square for the king if King here just
Queen e7 check picks up the bishop if
you go here let's say to g8 then Queen a
to check picks up the bishop and you're
just you're up of the shop and you
already have two very strong points if
you go somewhere like let's say Kings to
be eight then Queen to e3 picks up the
bishop so wherever the King goes you
pick up the bishop you rock material
easily winning game so really really
incredible stuff but yeah really really
complicated but basically with good best
play Queen to d7 is is is not the most
ambitious way to go the most ambitious
way to go about it is actually for the
mood that you get of place so again
everything is hanging what does white
play here capturing
with rook capture sandy one still runs
into the same defense after night to be
to the one we already discussed so you
cannot play like this however what you
can do is Knight captures any eight and
this is what a white plays so you just
grab the rook it doesn't matter that
blacks queen is hanging eke actress on
f3 that's that's the stuff so again what
do you play here again you could play
rook out for sandy one now it's a bit
different because after captures and
captures Bishop the f1 blocks and Bishop
to h3 now you can defend with Queen to
a-1 you can give up some material for
example rook captures you're gonna play
Queen captures and now well Mitchell
captures nf1 Bishop CalPERS and g7 and
now you're gonna move back the bishop
and we go into the same game with equal
material really incredible that such an
endgame is possible from all of that
madness but yeah after each character's
on f3
we have Bishop to c3 now white defense
the rook and asks what do you play now
and here it's possible to play Bishop
captures on c3 this is what now what
Puranic was going for because now after
captures the rook is defended you're
threatening to capture the Queen but
also you're threatening mate so it seems
like this is completely winning for
white however Queen d4 stops all of this
and white what black is just better this
is a threat this is a threat this is a
threat so black would be winning here
however sugar of finds and finds an even
more interesting move rook to d3 so
what's a rook to d3 you might ask well
he piles up on the bishop here he still
doesn't care about his Queen and he
basically forces now rook captures on d1
so this is what quranic plays we have
rook captures and d1 this is the
strongest move rook captures and be one
with Czech Bishop to f1 and now again
Bishop to h3 doesn't do anything Queen
to a-1 is still a viable defense so we
have Bishop characters on c3 and now the
problem is you cannot recapture because
if you capture with the Queen then
Knight d4 just wins yeah you block mate
so there's that but also Knight the e2
check is coming you'll have to play King
h1 and rook captures on f1 will be made
so instead of capturing of course you
cannot just wait around for the short eh
to read to happen here Queen to b3 was
played but now what do you play Queen b3
attacks the rook you don't have time for
Bishop to h3 what do you play here feel
free to pause the video and try to find
it yes it's a mate in seven so well I
have a nice if of my water so for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's it's really just a
beauty on the board such a such a
spectacle of pieces so really for those
of you who found it really just
congratulations not an easy one to find
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's a rook captures an
f1 that's that's what happens here you
don't have time for any any slow moves
so just look characters 194 doesn't work
here because you just pick up the rook
and then there's no actual threat 90 to
check you just pick up with the bishop
so rook captures an f1 wins with King
captures on f1 and now worship the h3
with Czech but after what captures on f1
it was in this position that Abhimanyu
Puranic actually resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
but just to show you the variation King
captures Bishop the h3 would check these
two squares are taken so the King has to
go back to g1 also taken King to g1 and
now Knights to d4 and now this is deadly
because if the queen is under attack if
you capture the brush of 90 to check
King h1 and Bishop to g2 delivers in
mate this is really really impressive
stuff and after 94 if we don't capture
the bishop if you try something else
there is not much you can try Knight f6
check okay you can give one checking h8
there on there aren't any more checks
Queen to d1 now just offering some
material but it still doesn't help you
just 92 check and now you either go into
the same mate or you have to play this
because it's a silly move but it is
considered the best defense because
white survives the longest but so
whatever move you play now doesn't
really matter you're just gonna play
something and well let's say f3 f4
doesn't really matter
and II won Queens the pond with wit mate
so really incredible stuff this after
this Queen to b3 guru captures an f1
white resigned and there we have it this
beautiful game I don't know if you've
seen it it's it would be ashamed not to
see this game it was not just the final
position not just the the tactics but
also all the tactics and and everything
after that night the c4 sacrifice just
beautiful stuff so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoy that I would like to
thank the Barry makhmur duck motto
Cheryl younger Roberto young Scott Meyer
and Edward didn't think for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
poem or fee saga and of course checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and do
check out sugar versus Carlson if you
haven't the first link in the
description below so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day